[Music]
it began with what people describe as a
sudden downpour Of Cinders driven by
Fierce winds in just minutes they turned
these homes into an
inferno Roxana Messa tells us everyone
on her street is pitching in to clear
the rubble the only thing left of their
possessions except for the clothes on
their
back we Run for Our Lives helping our
elderly neighbors we all helped but
three neighbors died the Heat and the
Flames were inar
these are the deadliest wildfires in the
history of Chile a country already
familiar with natural disasters hundreds
remain missing presume
dead firefighters continue working day
and night to control the fires in the
densely populated valaro
region Brigade Chief hos Hae who's been
fighting fires for 40 years
says he's convinced they were started
deliberately they started simultaneously
at exactly the same hour in six
different places when the winds were
extremely strong humidity very low and
the temperatures high but not enough to
ignite a fire on its own this was no
accident the government appears to agree
and vows to find and punish the culprits
what might have taken minutes to light
could take weeks to extinguish this may
look like a very small fire right now
but this is a pine tree or what's left
of it and the real significant thing is
what's underneath and that is the roots
of the tree they're very deep they go
all the way down here all the way up
there so when you think youve put out
the fire it can ignite at any moment
unless the firefighters keep coming back
and back again to try to extinguish
it Nestor Mania lost everything his car
his home and his livelihood an enormous
Greenhouse house for growing and selling
exotic plants luckily he was away when
it all went up in smoke unlike his dog
Napoleon who survived but just
barely there had been fires before up in
the hills but this time homes were lost
and I've been living here 30
years neighboring countries are offering
help which Chile will need as reports
emerge of new wildfires further south
Lucia Newman Al jazer in the valaro
region
Chile make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer